as we mentioned we're learning stunning
new details this morning about president
trump's
financial dealings as discovered by the
new york times
the latest report shows a pattern of
massive losses
in stark contrast to the president's
image as a successful businessman
cbs news has not independently confirmed
the data
paula reed has more from the white house
president trump steered clear of
questions monday about the damaging new
york times report on his finances
but hours later the times published new
details further illustrating president
trump's financial troubles
including an over 350 million dollar
loss reported at the end of 2002. and
nearly 90 million dollars in losses from
his signature business in 2003
but following the success of his reality
show the apprentice
according to the times mr trump cashed
in on a 500 thousand dollar deal to sell
double stuff oreos and another half
million dollar contract from domino's
pizza
there were also seven-figure licensing
deals with hotel builders
some in the former soviet republics the
times reports mr trump licensed his name
to bayrock group
a development company it says documents
show bayrock pursued financial backing
in russia
to pay for hotels bearing the trump name
the times reviewed one plan titled
russian fee agreement which called for
50 million dollars
for three trump hotels in the u.s
democrats note the president
is personally responsible for around 420
million dollars in loans
most of which will come due over the
next four years
this president appears to have over 400
million dollars in debt 420 whatever it
is
million dollars in debt to whom
white house officials have questioned
the timing of these reports they
certainly give
former vice president joe biden new
material for tonight's debate
and president trump was expected to
really focus on biden's son hunter
and money that he made through foreign
contacts but these revelations
undercut that argument some house
republicans are now calling for an
investigation
into how the new york times obtained the
president's financial records
something that some lawmakers and even
prosecutors have been having to fight
for
in court tony looking at the how rather
than what they mean paul thank you very
much